the very presence of the Russian foreign
minister at this Gathering led to a
boycott by Ukraine Poland and the Baltic
Nations Bulgaria refused to let Sergey
lro's plane through its airspace Sergey
La followed by and once he was
introduced several delegates walked out
his message when it came was that the
organization for security and
cooperation in Europe had been
captured the occe is essentially being
turned into an extension of NATO and the
European Union the organ ation let's
face it is teetering on the edge of a
precipice some members blame Russia for
pushing it to the brink occe monitors
left eastern Ukraine after Russia's
fullscale Invasion last year but the
organization has issued several reports
on alleged war crimes and crimes against
humanity by Russian
troops now Moscow is accused of
deliberately paralyzing the body's
decision-making process and starving it
of
funds the Russian government's de
sightful game is and always has been to
use its brutal war of aggression against
Ukraine to also destroy organizations
that rely on peaceful coexistence and
cooperation and we will not allow that
to happen others though have cautiously
welcomed Russia's presence here the
European Union's foreign policy Chief
Joseph Bell calling it a means of
keeping multilateralism alive and there
was full throated support from Hungary
the weapon deliveries prolong the war
and we don't need War we don't need
weapons in the region what we need in
the region is peace it's conflict though
that prevails in Ukraine and in east
west diplomacy Harry foret Al jazer